[Musique]
une longue complainte sur la place
sainte sophie comment est ce possible de
ne pas t'aimer kiev dit la chanson une
musique nostalgique qui semble exprimer
aussi la lassitude d'un pays en guerre
ici les ukrainiens qui contemple chaque
jour les épaves d'équipement russe
calciné sorte de trophée de guerre
espère de choses
[Musique]
sa petite famille espère que son
président réussir à convaincre les
partenaires étrangers de fournir
davantage d'armes à son pays et toi tu
as vu quand irene a eu facile si l'on
vit plus que tout de faire partie de la
grande famille européenne
à quelques coins de rue de ces souhaits
de grandes pointures pour peut-être les
exaucer emmanuel macron mario draghi et
olaf scholz une première en sol
ukrainien
les discussions sont sérieuses les
demandes ukrainienne entendu
l'europe est à vos côtés réaffirme le
président français elle le restera
autant qu'il le faudra jusqu'à la
victoire qui aura le visage du retour de
la paix dans une ukraine libre et
indépendant l'allemagne elle promet
d'autres livraisons d'armes
et puis surtout l'italie annoncent le
soutien commun des trois partenaires
pour soutenir le traitement immédiat de
la candidature de l'ukraine au sein de
l'union européenne et que l'italie
craint
le président ukrainien fera tout ce
qu'il peut pour que ce rêve devenu
besoins essentiels deviennent aussi
réalité ce
match-là et autres images
oubliées donc les frictions entre
emmanuel macron et le président
zielinski à cause de commentaires
récents du président français sur la
nécessité de ne pas humilier la russie
et vladimir poutine la relation serait
au beau fixe
dans les ruines de la ville d'hier
pineau porte de kiev la france salue le
courage de ce peuple face à l'évasion
russe donc je vote représentait
l'héroïsme inde de l'armée mais aussi de
de la population le besoin urgent
d'armement pour l'ukraine et combler
petit à petit par les pays européens
mais pas assez rapidement estime kiev
quant à la demande d'adhésion européenne
là il faudra attendre l'unanimité parmi
les 27 pays membres de l'union avant que
le dossier de candidature soit étudié
une procédure qui si accéléré soit elle
pourrait prendre des mois voire des
années là encore volodymyr zelensky
devra s'armer de patience ici frédéric
arnould radio-canada à kiev en ukraine